Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
concluding our mention of the great
companion Abu
the mention of his biography
with as much summary as possible. Abu
after the passing of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, he was of course
with
the messenger in every single battle,
every subsequent battle after the battle
of
up until the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's passing
and Abura
was later
made the governor of Bahin in the time
of Omar
and he was after concluding that
position made the MUI and Muadith of
Medina
and his students
as Bkari tells us
that he has more than 800 students. Now
the question that a lot of people ask is
why are Abu's narrations more
more numerous than the narrations of
other more knowledgeable more major
companions of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. some of which were not only
his companions in Islam, were not only
from
but were even his companions before
Islam or family members. And the answer
to that is a couple of things. Number
one, Abuah
was considered a smaller companion. When
we say smaller, right, we're not talking
about size. We're not talking
necessarily
about position, but we are talking
about age. He was a younger companion.
And he had completely
cleared himself of everything except for
that function. And so that is all he did
was narrate the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam's narrations and teach the
students very similar to ib Abbas when
he was in Mecca.
Why? Because the other more major
companions Abu Bakr Omar Ali etc.
They were busy with the Islamic
government. They were not as accessible.
They did not have specific places
where all they did was narrate or all
they did was teach. They had other
positions to fill. Abu
that was his only position and that was
his only thing that he did.
Also, Abu Hurra lived far
on because of his young age past the
time of the four
the
obviously was
was a number of decades. However, after
that we had the kingship of Muawi
and a lot of things started to change in
the Muslim government. A lot of
things started to change and shift and
Abu Hurra continued to live on until the
year 59 after Hijra which is considered
to be a long time past the more than two
decades past the time of Ali.
Another thing is that Abu Huray was not
in Iraq Iraq in the time of Ali and
Abib
when he moved the Muslim capital to Iraq
from Medina. Some people might think how
could you move the Muslim Empire's
capital from the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's city to Iraq, right? That is
absolutely necessary and it was one
considered to be one of the most
intelligent, one of the most successful
decisions that the made and
who made. Why? Because that was the
those were the front lines of the
expanding Muslim empire. The Muslim
Empire was expanding so quickly that it
would have been almost impossible
to maintain order and civility in these
new territories if the Katha was so far
deep into the Arab Peninsula. You have
to imagine say let's say something
happens in past the river
the Euphrates River or let's say
something happens going into the
Roman territories or the Persian
territories
some kind of civil unrest some kind of
battle some kind of and so they have to
send word back to the Kilfa right they
had to send word back to the capital.
Imagine if that word instead of taking a
week or two is now taking months on end
to arrive there, have a decision made
and send back that decision. Things have
completely changed from what was being
what the information was originally,
right? Rebellions could have started,
they could have ended, entire battles
would be lost. And so it becomes almost
impossible to have a an expanding
Muslim empire with such speed to where
communication is so slow to the head or
so slow to the capital. Therefore
did move the capital to Iraq. It
remained there for centuries to come.
Abu
narrated a lot of narrations and of them
were the narrations of the prophecies of
the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam. When you look at the prophet's
prophecies, the things that he informed
us about. He informs us of things that
are going to happen in the future as a
function. It's not just for us to know.
So he's going to inform us of things
before they happen in order that we can
prepare for them in order that we can
expect them so that we are not
blindsided by them. So when you look
into the prophecies that he left us when
he passed away sallallahu alaihi
wasallam you see that those prophecies
are concentrated
on two main eras. First is immediately
after his death saiam
and continuing on about into the first h
100red years we have a lot of prophecies
about leaders and government and
leadership and things that would occur
wars battles discord you know
conflicts etc. things that would happen
immediately after his death and about a
hundred years on after his death sai
wasam. These serve a purpose. The next
cluster of prophecies focus on when
humanity is gearing up and preparing for
the emergence of a gel. Those prophecies
are very heavy as well. So these major
events that happen, this is where we
find the most numerous prophecies and
what he spent most time speaking about
with regards to things that will occur.
And so being that he narrated
Abua narrated so many narrations of the
prophecies
of things that would occur immediately
after his death.
He was
scrutinized
very deeply by the new governing force
and the new folks that were starting to
take over in the Muslim government.
especially around and after the time
of
and of course
was in Hashem. So he was he was all the
way in Syria. So what was going on in
Medina had to send governors to be in
these different places. And many of
these governors
were
many of these governors that took
over after Muawa were not the most
savvy, not the best of characters. And
so because of this, there were many
narrations that Abu
would narrate to his close companions.
He would not publicly narrate them. and
narrations that he would publicly
narrate but very vaguely of things
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
prophesized and one of those prophecies
was that Abu was known to make the dua
[Silence]
He would say, "Oh Allah, I seek refuge
in you from the leadership of the
foolish
and the year 60."
And so Abu passed away in the year 59
after Hijra.
What occurred in the year 60 after hijra
Yazid Iban Muawi took over the
governance and it was considered to
be a disaster and a lot of difficult
times came upon the Muslim and
specifically the companions of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam after
that Abu Huray was from dos is a
place in Yemen a lot of people don't
know that do is one of the regions that
actually offered the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam harbor and
offered him a place to make his hijra
to. Do is one of those places that when
they became Muslim and Abu was the first
of dose to become Muslim they had
offered to the prophet sallallahu alaii
wasallam to come and make hijra to do
and that they would protect him.
basically what the Ansar did in Medina.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
declined that offer. But could you
imagine how different the history of the
world would have been and the history of
Islam and the Muslims would have been if
Medina was not where it is today and if
it was Yemen. It would have been very
very different. very different things.
so with that as we mentioned Abu
passed away in the year 59 after hijra
he was born roughly 21 years before
hijra
which makes him pass which would mean
that he passed away at about 80 years
old. ,
and so Abu Hurra is one of the most
important companions for us to know and
study and keep up with his life and
times.
And obviously this is a very quick
thing. Three days basically is a quick
thing. We haven't even scratched the
surface. Abu
has volumes of books that have been
written about him, about his students,
about his narrations, about his
knowledge.
We will be sufficed with that for
today. Inshallahhammed.
Alhamdulillah.